for Elaine Levy's daughter Fallon
Healthcare comes at an enormous cost
she's been paying tens of thousands of
pounds a year for medical cannabis
privately to treat her severe epilepsy I
couldn't keep up with the mortgage
payments keep up with my daughter and
it's like paying more than a mortgage
you know it's like you know my children
were like you can't carry on like this
so I actually did sell my home medical
cannabis was legalized in 2018 but a
lack of Trials and clinical research
means the NHS has so far only prescribed
it to fewer than five people we were
promised an observational trial and an
RCT a random controlled trial so that we
could actually help the children that
were already on medical cannabis and
indeed do data for children that aren't
on it and we have never been we've never
seen the money we've never had a meeting
since with the government they've
basically ignored us on Monday Elaine
and fellow campaigners with the group
and our pain a writing to health
secretary Stephen Barkley
urging him to fund the relevant research
we haven't had that right type of
research that can convince Regulators
guideline bodies and day-to-day
clinicians in the NHS for it to be
prescribed on a population basis across
all people with those conditions so
while some go private others are pushed
to the extremes when Haley's husband
Neil was diagnosed with incurable brain
cancer she tried to treat His Pain by
sourcing medical cannabis illegally
at the time they were struggling to walk
he was struggling to get out of the
house and that was where they told us
that Neil only had six weeks to eight
weeks to live
so we were desperately clutching at
straws and wanted to do more you are
very isolated it's a black market you're
on your own you've got to do your own
research and you just hope that what
you're buying is what what they say
you're buying a spokesperson for the
Department of Health says they're
working with Partners to establish
clinical trials to test the safety and
effectiveness of more cannabis-based
products before they can be considered
for wider rollouts on the NHS but for
Elaine and thousands of families like
hers the wait continues spending more
and more money on medication they hope
will prove to be life-changing Rachel
Venable's Sky News